اكد قادت الدول العربيه خلال انطلاق اعمال
مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون والشراكه في دوراته
الثانيه على ان المنطقه بحاجه الى
الاستقرار والسلام العادل والشامل واقال
العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني ان
امن العراق ركن اساسيون في امن المنطقه
فيما اوضح رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
الشيعه السوداني رغبه بغداد في ارساء
وتعزيز الشراكه الاقليميه والدوليه
واستتباب الامناء بينما عبر وزير الخارج
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان عن ترحيب
المملكه استعاده العراق لدوره الاقليمي
والدولي ورفض اي اعتداء على اي شبر من ارض
العراق
كما تؤكد المملكه وقوفها جنب الى جنب مع
وترجمه
تحقق نتائج
العراق الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
التام لاننا مائها ورخائها
يرتباطا وثيقا بنبات
ورخاء جيرانها
وجدد الرئيس الفرنسي
دعم بلاده للعراق مرددا بالتاثيرات
الخارجيه التي يتعرض لها داعيا في الوقت
نفسه الدول المشاركه في القمه الى
المساعده في تعزيز امن العراق والمنطقه
وامنه وسيادته ورخاء شعبه العراق اليوم
في قاعه واحده كل الدول والامم التي
يمكنها ان تساهم في تعزيز السياده العراق
وبالتالي استقراره وامن المنطقه